ونحن نواصل مع حضراتكم هذه التغطيه وينضم
الينا الان على الهواء مباشره السيد محمد
حمدان دغل قائد قوات الدعم السريع في
السودان مرحبا بك سيد حميدتي ربما السؤال
الذي يتبادر الى الاذهان في البدايه اين
تتواجد انت الان
داخل الخرطوم
طيب الفريق البرهان وهو في حديثه معنا
يقول انا لا احد يعرف مكان تواجدك حتى ان
قوتك لا تعرف اين تتواجد انت اذا كيف تدير
العمليات العسكريه وترسل التعليمات لقوتك
شبابنا
ولكن هو كان شريكك في المسار الذي تحدث
كنتم تسيرني معا للترتيبات الخاصه بمستقبل
السودان وفجاه تفرقت والبعض يقول ان هذا
الفراق كان لصراع على السلطه
السؤال يقول كنتم شركاء لبناء مستقبل
السودان انتم والبرهان وفجاه بدات
الخلافات وظهر الصراع واصبح يبدو انه صراع
على السلطه بينكما يضر بمستقبل السودان
البرهان من اول يوم في 11 ابريل هو استلم
استلم امانه امانه ما حقته هو استلم امانه
الاسلاميه
الخارجيه القطري
كلنا
هو يقول انك فقد السيطره على قوتك اصلا
وان هذه القوات تقوم بعمليات سلب ونهب
كبيره وبتعدي على الرعايه الاجانب بماذا
ترد على هذه الاتهامات
انا لا اجيب ان اطرح السؤال تفضل سيد حمد
ان
البيان اول ما طلع الموضوع
في اقفال الاخرين
قليل الادب الشديد رجعت للحركه الاسلاميه
وانا اقول حركه
الاسلاميه
والحركه الاسلاميه صادقه الكلام ده
طيب انت تقول ان البرهان مصير وليس مخير
من يحرك البرهان اذا كنت تقصد ان هناك
جهات معينه تقف خلفه
على راسهم علي كرتي على كر
دي مجموعه من
العلق
الان الاجانب موجودين داخل العمارات
طيب انا اريد ان يستمع اليك الجميع ما هو
خلافك مع البرهان الذي دفع الى هذا الصراع
هو يتهم قوات الدعم السريع بانكم من
اشعلتم فتيل هذه الازمه والصراع المسلح
حينما تحركت قوتكم الى مرو
ر
[موسيقى]
سودانيه
بوجودنا في مروي
نا
[تصفيق]
انا اريد ان يستمعوا ان يستمع اليك
الجمهور بشكل واضح ارجو ان نتواجد في مكان
ثابت حتى نستمع اليك بشكل جيد لان هذه
فرصه مهمه للاستماع اليك
طيب انتم طرحتم على البرهان او الجيش
السوداني قلتم انكم طرحتم الهدنه لاكثر من
مره ومع ذلك الجيش يقول انكم انتم من لا
يلتزمون بهذه الهدنه والدليل انكم تعتدون
على المدنيين تستخدمون المدنيين كدروع
بشريه تعتدون على المستشفيات ما ردك على
هذه الاتهامات لقواتك
انا اتمنى انا اتمنى العالم كله الحروب
تمت كلها في القنوات
اتمنى الكلام
اللي موجودين داخل
عشان يشوفوا
في المستشفى
اول ق
ولكن هو يقول انك لا تسيطر على قوتك وان
هذه القوات لا تلتزم بفكره الهدنه ان هناك
ربما الدعم السريع يريد هدنه ولكن القوات
لا تستمع الى تعليماتك وكان هذه القوات
تعمل من تلقاء نفسها دون قائد اعلى
القادم
[موسيقى]
طيب هو يقول انه لا يريد ان يلجا الى اليه
الهجوم حتى اللحظه وانه يكتفي بالدفاع عن
الهجمات التي تقومون بها وانتم تقولون نفس
الشيء الحقيقه ان السوداني يتالم هل من
فكره عاقل الان لايقاف هذه المواجهه
الحمد لله
ويقول انه داخل القياده العامه
هو يقول انه داخل القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه ويقود قواته
يا اختي العزيزه القوات المسلحه الان داخل
القياده ما تتجاوز 350
ومجبورين العسكريين يعني
طيب هو يقول انكم تلجاون الى قوات اجنبيه
قوات لا تعتمدون على قوات الدعم السريع
ككيان او كجنود وطنيين انكم تلجون الى
انا
الجيش
هذا
اول ما تم الحظر بطاقات له
هو شخص الان
يعني
هل هل تسمح للصحفيين بالتغطيه الحره لهذه
الاحداث ام ان هناك اتهامات تقول انكم
تمنعون الصحفيين
تماما احنا منقارب الصحفيين يكونوا معانا
طيب انا سعيده بانك معنا على الهواء لنطرح
عليك بعض التساؤلات بصراحه شديده الصوره
الذهنيه للناس الان انك تصارع البرهان على
السلطه وان من يدفع الثمن هو الشعب
السوداني وان هذا صراع شخصي من اجل السلطه
والتاريخ لن يسمح بان يتم التعامل مع هذا
الامر بتسامح هل تعتقد ان تاريخ سيضمك في
هذا في هذه الازمه
عندي شهود انا عندي الموقعين
البرهان
عمل انقلاب
هنا الان من د
يعني انت تقول ان البرهان فعل ذلك من اجل
السيطره على الحياه السياسيه ما يبدو
للناس ان الاطراف المدنيه بعيده الان وان
هذا صراع بينكما انتما الاثنين وليس
بينكما وبين الطيارات المدنيه مثلا
كالصوره المعتاده
لا لا لا غير صغير غير صغير الفراع باتفاق
الاقاري الصراع في اتقال السياسي
وعشان اتشارك السلطه انا
تعمل فيها
طيب من اجل التحول الديمقراطي
من اجل التحول الديمقراطي هل انتم على
استعداد للجلوس مع الفريق البرهان لوضع
ترتيبات معينه لفكر الخلافات بينكما فيما
يتعلق بمساله دمج قوات الدعم السريع هل
انتم على استعداد للجلوس
مع من تقعد اذن
انا
وما علاقه السياسيين بهذا الصراع الان انت
تتصارع مع البرهان او الدعم السريع يتصارع
مع الجيش السوداني ما علاقه القوى
السياسيه بالامر الان هذا صراع بينكما
انتما
كيف كيف العلاقه هو السياسيين موقع لاتفاق
الايطالي
قبل 25 ما عندي مشكله
طيب حل او وقف اطلاق النار كيف يتم سيد
حميدتي
وراج
عوا السودان انا
لكن ابدا
طيب سيد حمدتى اشرح لنا شيء يبدو غامضا
انتم كنتما معا ونجحتم في القضاء على
النظام السابق ثم تقول انت في هذه اللحظه
ان البرهان عاد من جديد الى فلول النظام
السابق من الحركه الاسلاميه والمتطرفين
واصبح معهم واصبحوا يسيطرون على المشهد
كيف حدث هذا الانقلاب بين ليله وضحاها
[موسيقى]
السلطان
الثاني يقول عارف المراه من اول يوم وهو
عشان ارجع الحركه الاسلاميه
مجموعه الحركه الاسلاميه
طيب لماذا صمدت كل هذه الفتره الماضيه
وتعلن هذا الامر الان
حتى جهاز الامن الان
هو
الان والله
النادر الان الشغل
حتى في الحركه
فيقول البعض
سيقول البعض لماذا تقول هذا الكلام في هذا
التوقيت بعد ان حدث اصطدام في مساله ضم
قوات الدعم السريع تحت قياده واحده وكانك
التزمت الصمت وحينما تعلق الامر بك شخصيا
وبقوتك بدات الحديثه بهذه اللغه
والدليل يا اختي العزيزه الان النادي
الانقلاب في قبل 25 امر انقلاب
جابوا لك
دفاع الشع
بي رجعوا كلها
رجعوه الان متقاتلين
يعني
قوات الدعم السريع ايضا خلال ايام الماضيه
في سجن الهدى سمحت بهروب عدد من السجناء
وانها اثارت حالها من الفوضى في السجون
بما انك تتحدث عن هذه النقطه
لا اسمعك جيدا تفضل
ولكن هو يقول انه لن يخرج من مركز القياده
العامه الى اعلى نعش وانه يفعل ذلك من
واجب من واجبه الوطنيه باعتباره قائدا
اعلى للقوات المسلحه السودانيه
[موسيقى]
نعم
ما الذي يعني هذه العباره تعني انكم ستظل
في مواجهه مسلحه والفاتوره يدفعها
المدنيين سيدتي
للاسف الشديد انسان
اعود الى الموقف
الدولي
هذا الخطاب وهذه الامور التي تتحدث بها
الان لابد انك تحدثت فيها مع انطوني
بلانكن وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه حينما
اتصل بك يوم الخميس الماضي ماذا دار
بينكما
اتصل بك وزير الخارجيه الامريكي يوم
الخميس الماضي ما الذي دار بينكما
الموظفين
[موسيقى]
هل تعتقد ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تاخذ موقفا مناصرا لك
50 مليون
انا لا تريد السلطه
انت لا تريد السلطه ولكن هناك معارك تدور
على الارض الان تبدو انها صراع على السلطه
سيد حميدتي الناس لا تفهم ما الذي يحدث
التحول الديموقراطي الحقيقي لمن اجل
العداله دي من اجل الوطنيه ان احنا بنقاتل
من اجل من اجل السودان
من هو الطرف الوسيط الذي يمكن ان يلعب من
هو الطرف الوصف
طيب
من هو الطرف الوسيط الذي ترضى بان يكون
راعيا للوساطه بينك وبين قوات الجيش
السوداني بقياده البرهان هل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هل طرف امريكيه هل قوه
داخليه
كل الامور
كل شيء مسيطرين على كل شيء
يعني الان الشعب
السودانيين بيقولوا انهبه
اليوم
واحنا الان موجودين اتمنى انه
طالما انت ترى ان الجيش يسيطر على كل شيء
موازين القوى ليست لصالحك اذا وفقا لهذا
التقييم
انا بتكلم على
الامر المدني انت ما تفهم يعني غلط
المياه والصحه والخدمات
اذا من يسيطر على هذه الخدمات التي تعتبر
عصب السودان الان
اذا هي مجموعات وفقا لتوصيفك ليست تابعه
لك لا تدين بالولاء لك وبالتالي انت في
معركه غير متكافئه
اصلا
[موسيقى]
عباره
طيب سيد حماتي انا اتحدث مع قائد عسكري
بالتاكيد لديك حسابات عسكريه دقيقه الموقف
العسكري الان هل هو لصالحك ام ضدك مع مرور
الايام هل هذا استنفاذ لقواتك لصالح الجيش
الذي يعد مؤسسه عسكريه كبيره لديها قوات
متنوعه ومختلفه
خيار الشعب
وما يمشي في في هدف البرهان لكن للاسف
الشديد
الان الجيش تدمر تماما القوات الفلاحه
الجو طلع تمام
وفضلة
المدرعات انتهت تماما الان داخل
مدرعيه تماما
على الهواء الان انت معي على الان على
الهواء الان كقائد على لقوات الدعم السريع
قل لي ماذا تسيطرون في الاماكن تسيطرون في
السودان الان خاصه ان كل طرف منكم يدعي
السيطره على الخرطوم وعلى المطارات وعلى
بعض المنشات الحيويه وعلى القياده العامه
على ماذا تسيطر قوات الدعم السريعه رسميا
وفقا لك انت الام
المشاهدين وانا من هنا
ويعني في العيد لاني والله يعني
المهندسين
هناك عندهم
طيب ما هي شروطك على الهواء الان ما هي
شروطك على الهواء الان لايقاف هذه
المواجهات المسلحه بينكم وبين قوات الجيش
السوداني
ولكن الا ترى ان هذا هدف غير واقعي ان
تتحدث عن القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه تقول له وتطالب
طب اذا ما رفض البرهان وهو امر متوقع لهذا
الامر وهو يقول لك انه لن يخرج من القياده
العامه الا على نعش
اذا سيستمر الصراع
ويستمر تستمر المواجهات ويستمر القتل
المدنيين لا بديل اخر سوى استسلام البرهان
كله
الديمقراطيه
بالطريقه الثانيه
طيب انت تقول انا شرطك
لانهاء هذا الصراع هو استسلام البرهان طب
ما هي شروط المتاحه الان لفكره عقدهن
وهدنه حقيقيه على الارض وليست مجرد بيانات
اعلاميه
ولكن بالنسبه للهدنه
ما بيلتزموا
لانه ما في
الحكايه
خارج القياده العامه هو الان داخل القياده
العامه
ما في عنده حاجه هو
طيب اذا لم يستسلم البرهان بالتاكيد هناك
قنوات تستمع الى ما تقوله الان قنوات
سياسيه قريبه من البرهان اذا لم يستسلم
البرهان ما هو البديل الاخر الان
في معرفه
يعني اما ان ينتصر احد منكما او طرف منكما
والا المعركه ستستمر
القتال هو الطالب انا ما طلبته انا دفعت
عن النفس انا النفس انا ما اعتقد عليه سيد
حميدتي هو يقول نفس الشيء سيد حميدتي يعني
ارجو ان تعذرنا كمشاهدين وكوسائل الاعلام
هو يقول نفس الحديث التي تتحدث به انكم
انتم منهاجمتم انكم انتم من اخللتم
بمستقبل السودان انكم انتم من ترفضون
الحكم المدني انكم انتم انتم تعرقون
المسار الديمقراطي هي اتهمات متبادله
من هم شهود هل لديك وثائق
طب قولي الجمهور من هم الشهود ما هي
الوثائق التي تحتفظ بها وتؤكد مواقفك جدا
في توازاتك وحساباتك الان كقائد على ماذا
تراهن هل على قوتك ومدى صلابتها في
المواجهه هل على نصره الشعب السوداني لك
وخاصه ان هناك حاله من الانقسام لا يمكن
التعويل عليها في داخل السوداني على دعم
القوى الاقليميه لك على دعم قوه دوليه لك
على ماذا تراهن
انا انا مع خيار الشعب أنا الشعب
السوداني
ماشيين في هدف سكه حديد ما بنغيروا
هدفنا السودان
هدفنا ما عندنا غير الهدف
السودان الشباب اللي بيموت الان في
الشوارع اكثر من سنتين
انا من 25 ما عندي وقت
الا التامين العامل هو المشتركه بتاعه
التامين
الشامل اما شروط المظاهرات
الوضعيه تحول ديمقراطي حقيقي مثل
البلاد
طيب دعني افكر معك بصوت عالي فيما يطرحه
البعض هل انت تريد ما يمكن تسميته بالخروج
الامن كصيغه وسطى يمكن بها انهاء الصراع
الحالي ان تخرج امنا الا تتم ملاحظه
ملاحقه قضائيا على اي امر او اي قضيه هل
هذا الامر مطروح في ذهنك وانت تعد
للسيناريوهات عده في هذه المواجهه
هل تفكر في فكره ان يوفر لك ما يسمى
سياسيا بالخروج الامن بمعنى انه لا تتم
ملاحقه قضائيا هل هذا يمكن ان يكون عادلا
بالنسبه لك لانهاء صراعك مع البرهان
هناك اتهامات لك في امور سابقه وقائع
سابقه في دارفور وهناك اتهامات في الموقف
الحالي الان هل اذا ما تم التواصل الى
صيغه لفكره خروج امن لك هل يمكن ان توافق
بهذه الصوره
انت عارفه يا اختي العزيزه اول حاجه
الحكايه دي كلها هنيجي نتكلم فيها طن
واحده واحده
اي جرائم الحمد لله والشكر لله رب
العالمين انا ما عندي انا من البدايه اول
يوم قعدت قدام المجرمين غلط
لكن ما ممكن تمشي الحلاق
طيب البرهان والجيش السوداني يصفكم
بالمتمردين في بياناته يقول لا يقول قوات
الدعم السريع ويقول المتمردين
السودان
على السلطه من اجل الثروه يقولون انك
تسيطر بشكل كبير جدا على منابع مهمه
للثروه كالذهب بماذا ترد على هذه
الاتهامات ايضا
والله اسمع كلام اختي العزيزه اول حاجه
هو مسك
ين نعمه انا انا من كثر
الذهب ما قصه الذهب طالما الاعلام الاجنبي
يصفك بانك يعني من الذين يسيطرون على
مناجم الذهب وعلى هذه الثروه
كتاب مفتوح كل المناجم حقتنا هذيك
قديم والشركه
الشركه
ربنا
ما قصر
الاقليم من يساندك من يواصل الاتصال معك
ويدعم مواقفك او من يحاول الاتصال بك
لتقريب وجهات النظر بينك وبين الفريق
البرهان
من يساندك شخصيا في موقفك من من الدول
يدعمك
انا انا داير مثلث الشعب السوداني باي
دوله انا مساعد الشعب السوداني فقط لاننا
الان من ضحي
من اجل هل بالفعل قامت قوتك باسر الجنود
المصريين ودخلت في ازمه مع السلطات
المصريه بشان هذا الملف
الجنود المصري
صليب الاحمر مع الجنود هناك مفهوم معين
لهذه المعامله انهم اسرى
طب تتواصل مع القياده المصريه ليست لديك
مشكلات معها تقبل بان تلعب بعض الاطراف
العربيه والاقليميه دور الوساطه
لو سمحت ما سمعتك ما سمعت السؤال كويس
تقبل بان تلعب بعض الاطراف العربيه دور
الوساطه ومنها مصر باعتبار ان الامر يتعلق
بحدودها الجنوبيه امن قومي بالنسبه لها
[موسيقى]
اي انسان
بساعد الشعب السوداني بدايه يعني استغلال
السودان حين
طب وماذا مع التواصل مع الاشقاء العرب
ايضا الامارات والسعوديه
هل وقفت ضد عمليات اجلاء الرعايه يقولون
بعض الاتهامات من الجيش السوداني انك كنت
تحاول علقله وحتى اللحظه اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب
نعم
يا اختي العزيزه اختي العزيزه انا شايفك
انت انا لكن انت محمله عليها كثير
وما صادق مشكلته
سيد حمدتي انا صحفيه العب دوري في طرح
الاسئله التي تقال في الاوساط العامه ليست
وجهه نظري او وجهه نظري المحطه لو كنت
تابعت معنا لقاء السيد البرهان ستجد اننا
طرحنا عليه نفس الاسئله وبحياديه تامه نحن
فقط نعبر عما يدور في الاذان وليست وجهات
نظر وايضا مساله طرح السؤال تعطي لحضرتك
وكنت واسع الصدر معي للاجابه على
التساؤلات المطروحه
ليش
هل تؤمن وجود الصحفيين على الارض هل تؤمن
وجود الصحفيين على الارض ليس الصحفيين فقط
سيدي ولكن ايضا البعثات الخاصه او الفرق
الخاصه بالدعم الانساني عاجزه عن الوجود
على الارض لمساعده المحتاجين لان ليس هناك
وضع امني امن بالنسبه لهم
كلامك صح كلامك صح لكن اي صهر غالبا
لكن حيكون في مناطق امنه وينقل الحقيقه
فقط ان شاء الله
موجوده اين الان
قواتنا مجموعات كبيره جدا
هل تستسلم يوما
يستسلم يا رب
ماذا ستفعل لو انتصرت اذا ما تم حسم
العمليات على ايه حال هناك وضع عسكري كل
منكم يقول انه مسيطر ولكن لنحسب ان هناك
سيناريو ان قوات الدعم السريع سيطرت ماذا
ستفعل
وا الحكومه فتره الانتقاليه ووصل لتحول
ديمقراطي حقيقي
في كل دقيقه والتالي انا عندي مبدا ما
اتغير مبدئي انا مكتبي
الشعب السوداني انه لازم يكون في تحول وهل
ستخرج خارج العمليه السياسيه ان تبقى
حاضرا في منصب ما
شيه
لكن للاسف الشديد
المسلحه القوات المسلحه
المسلحه شرفاء القوات المسلحه قوات الدعم
السريع القوات
المسلحه الشرفاء القوات المسلحه من القوات
المسلحه طيب من يسمعك الان الاطفال الذين
يبكون في بيوتهم الامهات والرجال الكبار
في السن هذا الوضع الانساني الحساس
والمؤلم للغايه ماذا تقول لهم الان عبر
شاشه العربيه
اول حاجه اقول لهم انا اسف جدا انا اسفين
جدا جدا جدا جدا ونحن متاسفين فرض علينا
البرهان احنا ملتزمين يعني بالهدنه
والهدنه بتخليهم يطلعوا ويتعالجوا
ويشوفوا اغراضهم
نحن جاهزين انه نحن من اجل من اجل
السودانيين مع ان لاي مانع انا انا اعلنت
الهدنه من طرف واحد والان بقول
الاطفال والشباب والشابات
طلقه انا اربع سنين انا انقلاب
كذا انقلاب
الشديد البرهان في خطر جدا انه هو قال
الرجال الحركه الاسلاميه للسلطه والحركه
الاسلاميه
حقنا من الدماء يجب ان ان يقوم احد
الطرفين الان سواء انت او الفريق البرهان
بحقن هذه الدماء واعلان انه سيتم وقف
اطلاق النار مهما كانت خسائر اي من
الطرفين هل تمتلك شجاعه اتخاذ قرار من هذا
النوع
انا ما عندي مانع لكن البرهان ما يمشي
انقلاب انقلاب
انا ما اعرف انتم ابتليت تتكلموا عربي
انقلاب وبعده انقلاب فانا ما اعرف
الانقلاب
عنده الانقلاب لا يمكن التفاوض المرابط
يمشي
طيب وانت تجلس مع نفسك في ختام الايام قبل
بشكل جيد وانت قائد لهذه العمليات ام لا
تنام
[موسيقى]
وانت وانت تقلد الى النوم في ماذا تفكر هل
تفكر انك ستلاحق ستقتل سيتم الاضرار بك
ستنتصر يعني ما هي الاحلام التي تاتي اليك
او الكوابيس ان صلح التعبير
ينصركم
ماذا سيكتب التاريخ عنك القائد الذي تمرد
على البرهان وقاد حركه مسلحه ام انك ترى
ان التاريخ سيكتب انك انقذت السودان
اشكرك على هذه المقابله وعلى سعد صدرك لكل
الاسئله السيد محمد
تفضل
المواطنين والاجانب وترحيب باي مبادلات
دوليه تجنب المدني ولايه الحرب
نعم السيد محمد حمدان دقلو متحدثا الينا
في هذا الحوار على مدى الساعه الماضيه
للعربيه شكرا لك على هذه المقابله وعلى
ساعه صدرك لكل الاسئله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات